good morning believe nation today's
message is hustle over to you Timothy
Sykes the key to being successful is to
work harder than other people because
everybody wants success everybody wants
to Lamborghini everybody wants freedom
but what are you willing to do to get
there that's my question to you
you know we're here at the most
prestigious university in America
Harvard fantastic and very honored thank
you for having me here the people who
have gotten here have worked their butts
off to get here but that's just the
beginning whether you're in college
you're gonna go to college or you're out
of college this is a lifelong journey
where you have to continually work hard
work harder than other people to get
ahead a lot of people give up at
different times I'm no longer at that
stage you know when I had my big loss I
basically gave up for a year I was in
the gutter but I came back and I said
you know what this was a mistake that I
made investing it wasn't the patterns I
didn't go against what I had learned to
make all my millions before this loss I
invested and I didn't do my full due due
diligence and that was my mistake
I eventually got back into trading I saw
more patterns and I became the number
one ranked trader at a 50,000 unco
Wester in 2007 to 2011 every time I
think about this message I think about
Jerry Seinfeld and one of my favorite
bits of advice and Jerry Seinfeld is you
need to find the thing that most people
consider torture
it's the torture that you can endure
where when people look at your schedule
they would see it as torturous look at
what I do look what I do on YouTube so
many people write in they tweet me the
email me asking how do you do so many
videos I'm having a hard time doing one
video a week
[Music]
it's torture if you were to look at my
schedule it would be torture making
three videos at least a day going to the
YouTube channel on top of responding to
all the comments that come in we get
hundreds of comments every day that we
respond to on top of keeping track of
all the requests right for the top ten
series we have over 2,500 requests just
and we keep track of it we keep note and
we see how many people voted for
different people and then we start
making those videos on top of come up
with new series ideas for we can test
out it'd be so easy just to keep with
the same formula but it's not enough
it's got to get better we've got to grow
we've got to improve it's torture you
would look at our schedule and say
there's no way I want to do that much
work but it's why I've gotten better
it's why I went from the worst of my
agency to the best because while they
couldn't do everybody else was having
trouble doing one video a week I was
doing multiple videos a day it's that
hustle and it's not to say that I'm
great anybody can accomplish it you just
have to find the thing that you can do
that would look like torture to other
people so as an example I had Neil press
Rita on my channel we did a top 10 his
top 10 together and afterwards we're
talking about his book he has a book it
sold over million copies and he was
giving me advice on how to sell the book
and one of the bits of advice that he
gave me was he would go to all the
bookstores around in the general area
and in Toronto we've got a lot of the
free book stores and find out if they
had at least one copy of the book in
store and he would drive there and he
would talk to the manager and he would
sign the book and he would have stickers
that said signed by author and he would
chat up the the manager and talk about
why he made this book and they would
because of that conversation profile a
little bit more at the store and when
people came in and asked them for a book
they would give that recommendation and
so that's how he would spend his days
drive to different bookstores chatting
up to different managers signing the
books putting the stickers on and I look
at that work I think that is torture
I couldn't do it I wouldn't I would I
would hate to do that to drive two hours
to go to a bookstore that had two copies
of my book to sign those books and chat
at the manager to get that you know him
or her to know me
so they'll recommend the book and put it
higher up and do that day in day out I
couldn't do it this too it's just it's
torture but that's what he did
and it's what he does and that's how
he's grown and created the business
around his book and his speaking now and
he's gone all in on that and it's
amazing you need to find the same thing
for you you need to find the thing you
can dedicate so much time to that you
can hustle so hard at that it's one
enjoyable like as much of it may seem
torturous for you to jump into my
youtube schedule I like it I enjoy the
work I'm doing I look forward to video
day I look forward to look in the
comments I look forward to seeing what
you taught us we can come up with I like
it and that's how we get better so what
is the thing that you can do constantly
and still get fueled by and improve and
get better and create more value that
other people would look at and say that
is torture that's the question of the
day what should the day what is the
thing that you do that you hustle so
hard at that nobody's gonna touch you
because it's torture for everybody else
leave it in the comments below then I'm
gonna join in discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to Ken Ritchie
Ken thank you so much you're picking up
a cup of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying reading it thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
hey believe nation for those of you who
want a little extra motivation on
hustling I'm including some bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy people can look
at me and it almost pisses them off that
it's like that guy gets results I'm
pissed right and kind of pissed them off
and then they got it like deny to
themselves and stuff you know yeah they
couldn't even see videos of nylons
that's an actress
it can't be he's uglier than me and he's
got a girl actress right no dude you
just didn't go out I didn't you didn't
I've actually thought sometimes of
creating a video called what I did while
you didn't do it or what I was doing
while you were no no I was thinking
calling it what I was doing while you
were doing what you were doing and I was
gonna like enact the whole thing so I
feel like what you were doing like
watching TV the like this what I was
doing like me just kind of hustling
through my life going through my boring
little menial repetitive tasks that I do
every day that improved me 0.000001
percent and that add up over time I
really think I should make a video
myself just going through my day and
just show me doing it every day so
people can see the menial slow boring
nature of progress because for every
public victory you have you have a
private victory you know for every kick
video I put up online there's those
hundreds of hours that I spent at home
looking at my video footage looking at
other speakers comparing it contrasting
it and learning how to be a better
speaker for every hot seat video that
you see of me where I do some epic that
blows your mind there's all that time
that I spent going out doing menial
little [ __ ] approaches again and
again and again and then going home and
looking at what I did and how I could
improve it and on and on for every
kick-outs
freaking out boot camp student that I
have that loved the program there's
those 50 weekends a year that I went out
and taught learned every little nuance
of the freaking thing again and again
and again for a decade so you know
that's kind of like what success is like
I hope that I am that you know I provide
an example of a guy who is untalented
funny-looking and shouldn't be able to
do it and is stunting on
all your faces and and you know and that
you can see that and say oh [ __ ] if that
little can do it I can do it how early
in life did you you're relentless
ambition begin did this happen when you
were very young you alluded to the fact
that you sold papers at age six or
something well I don't know it just I
don't really feel like I'm that
ambitious oh come on
I'd hate to follow you around for a week
yeah well I could be hard but I know a
lot of people that work hard my father
worked hard and set an example for me
and and I know a lot of people that work
hard what does that mean working huh
what is your day like hardest you know
hustle all day long you know he talked
about hustlers Pete Rose on the baseball
field I try and do that all day long and
that's what I think we need to do here
in America I mean the people working in
the American automobile industry we got
our hustle the Japanese we've got to get
that old roll up our sleeves and get
back to work man we'll get this country
out of trouble we can do anything better
than anybody else in the world that's
your life there's no but if we got a
real wake that's spirit that's what I
try and do with the Atlanta Braves is
get everybody hustling because it's it's
it's such a good example of the people
that are watching the program you want
enough fear is the disease hustle is the
antidote so in my day I already sound
like an old school dude
in my day we it was just tough man you
you start a company in 2001 good luck
right you can't count on funding you
can't count on sales you can't count on
anything but just crazy hustle and just
grit your teeth claw your way to success
there was just no easy way to do it what
I find is a lot of the entrepreneurs
today are much smarter than we were back
in the day they're like way smarter
you know they got blogs they know what
VCS are doing you know they know
everything that's going on in the space
there's a corpus of knowledge now that's
that makes entrepreneurs today much
smarter but there's liquidity in funding
especially on the angel side used to be
much harder to get an angel deal done
than a Siri
a deal now angel deals are a piece of
cake but what happens is I've seen a
number of entrepreneurs who who don't
have that hustle and they they're afraid
and they act out of that fear and when
you act out of that fear you make big
mistakes an example might be doing a
pre-emptive deal with a VC thinking
they're your friend an example might be
like not being hardcore and keeping your
job an example might be not you know a
lot of times it gets exposed through
deals you see that fear being exposed
through the deal cycle and so if you
find if you're an entrepreneur and you
find yourself afraid of something sack
up okay and start hustling hustling is
the antidote to fear go create your
success